à la spa une initiative de ma personne
qui me dit ah tiens j'aimerais bien
mettre mettre à l'écran mon histoire que
les gens venaient avec des idées de
biopic serait jouée par quelqu'un on m'a
proposé des séries très honnêtement j'ai
aussi pris peur que ces projets voient
le jour sans moi parce qu'encore une
fois ça aurait faussé la mémoire et je
me suis dit peut-être qu'il est temps
que je puisse partager la vérité et puis
surtout la beauté sert que pour les gens
la beauté c'était tout diam's et pas le
reste alors que pour moi la beauté c'est
c'était mélanie petit qui a essayé de se
construire en tant que diam's qui a pas
réussi et qui s'est trouvée après alors
moi voilà j'ai toujours dit mondial je
trouve qu'elle a elle a quand même eu
des cojones un de faire ce qu'elle a
fait c'est vrai qu'elle était en pleine
gloire et changer de vie comme ça et
elle s'est confiée sur son passé diam's
diam's a cartonné pendant dix ans avec
plus d'1 2 million d'albums vendus plus
pour elle la réussite s'est elle aussi
qu'une prison regardez pour aller
au début quand on se construit on se
construit sur sur une histoire qui est
très brut et qui est forte de base parce
que voilà c'est une histoire personnelle
c'était beaucoup de mes blessures et
tout ça et tout ça sauf qu'après bas
tout s'arrange en surface et donc ben
vous qui vous sentiez seul vous êtes
aimé par des millions
peut-être quelqu'un qui avait pas
d'argent d'un coup bas il a de l'argent
quelqu'un qui avait qui étaient un bon à
rien aux yeux de tous ce pas finalement
il devient quelqu'un qui a fait une
grande carrière donc ce qu'on est à ce
moment là c'est une réussite entre
guillemets alors que parfois au fond de
soi ça va pas et cette réussite là elle
devient parfois presque une prison
alors on va voir derrière extrait après
vous allez me dire si vous êtes choqués
par les critiques contre diam ceux qui
ont émergé à la suite de cette interview
lire également revenu sur ces périodes
les plus sombres à une époque où tout le
monde était persuadé qu'elle allait se
suicider regardez moi j'ai des frères
l'impression d'être de venir parler de
quelqu'un qui aurait dû être soignés
survivent entre away complètement mort
les miraculés
avait complètement complètement
c'est sûr et certain et pour vous ce nom
diam's qu'est ce qu'il évoque à quelle
femme s qui le renvoie à une femme qui
qui si elle n'avait pas trouvé la paix
seraient mortes ça c'est sur moi
normalement je suis morte ça c'est
certain c'est à dire que quand je
raconte vraiment que j'ai voulu mettre
fin à mes jours c'était c'était sérieux
et bien sûr il ya son documentaire salam
salam qui est sortie et ce qui a frappé
les gens il ya quelques années c'est de
voir diam's voilà sortir complètement du
star system et se consacrer à la
religion or lui a donné plus de détails
sur son rapport à la religion et prône
le respect entre les uns et les autres
regardez il ya eu énormément de
critiques
c'est pas parce que je suis pas comme
toi que je suis contre e3 et ça c'est
quelque chose au sein de ma famille qui
est hyper clair mon oncle c'est un grand
patron français avec tout ce que ça
implique tout on mange ensemble je suis
voilée et il me respecte et on on s'aime
comme ça qui vous dit que ceux qui vous
ont rejeté ceux qui n'ont pas compris
ceux qui ont même cru parfois vous étiez
embrigader endoctrinés vous ne voulez
pas dit quand même que vous les
comprenez oui oui parce qu'avec le temps
et avec le recul j'ai appris à
comprendre l'autre et je pense que c'est
nécessaire comme j'ai voulu qu'on me
comprenne est ce que vous êtes choqués
par les critiques montrent elles
remettaient aux titres bancaires juste
avant dans le documentaire diam's fond
en larmes lorsqu'elle évoque l'épisode
de paris match en 2009 qui avait dévoilé
des photos d'elle la montrant à la
sortie d'une mosquée regardez ça ce qui
m'a vendu le triste parce qu'il ya la
colère
contre le fait qu'on me voilà un truc
intimes de ma vie ça c'est clair mais ça
c'est gérable moi c'était vraiment par
rapport aux gens qui m'aimait je savais
qu'ils allaient
comme brise et l'amour qu'ils avaient
entre moi et le public
c'est vraiment fait ma femme
s'est vraiment fait de voir en fait les
jauges tu vois ce
se vider un peu parce que c'est ça un
peu qui s'est passé c'est à dire que
battu vend moins de disques donc il ya
moins de monde dans les concerts mais il
ya des gens il ya un groupe qui est là
et cela
a jamais je leur serai reconnaissant
alors
vous avez mis tous oui vous êtes choqués
par les critiques contre elle
gilles verdez je suis très choquée parce
que ce qu'on lui reproche c'est de
porter le voile d'être musulmane est de
faire du prosélytisme
or elle ne le fait jamais elle raconte
son histoire parce que comme l explique
son histoire allait lui être volées elle
parle d'une manière linéaire elle ne
s'apitoie pas sur elle même je trouve
son interview et le documentaire très
bien et je ne comprends absolument pas
ses critiques si quelqu'un allait faire
une retraite dans un monastère un
catholique dans un monastère on dirait
c'est formidable parce qu'elle porte le
voile on la critique c'est absurde alors
elle par le site ses souffrances
psychologiques elle a également évoqué
son internement ni en clinique
psychiatrique en 2008 et son addiction
aux médicaments dont elle n'arrivait pas
à sortir regarder retrouve dans une
petite salle petite chambre d'hôpital
ont confisqué tout ton téléphone on te
coupe du monde et puis toi tu te
demandes ok donc en fait vous allez
venir m'aider quoi et si même les
spécialistes
du cerveau ne pouvait rien faire pour
moi bah
voila je pense que dans ma tête j'ai un
peu abandonné et je me souviens depuis
la clinique et bungert commence à me
faire du mal en fait
et quand les infirmières et les gens
restent confus ça ils ont dit non ça y
est up et là bas là ils m'ont et un
hibou est un aimant quand je dis mon
étal ans et qui vont donner plein de
cash et
alors géraldine vous vous êtes alors
c'est vrai que là c'est la seule de
géraldine s'est pas une position facile
alors oui c'est une prise de parole un
peu accidentogène mais je vais
m'expliquer avec nuance et avec
discernement d'abord j'adore diam's j'ai
toujours adoré sa musique ma fille par
exemple écoute tous les mythes toutes
les musiques de diam's et la trouvent
effectivement dans ses prises de paroles
extrêmement touchante et bouleversante
donc ça je le remets pas en cause alors
après est-ce qu'on peut la critiquer je
vois pas pourquoi on n'aurait pas le
droit de la critiquer si on n'est pas
raciste si on n'est pas islamophobe si
on n'est pas voilà si c'est pas sous le
coup de la loi on a droit de critiquer
sa prise de parole on a voilà je trouve
que on a droit est ce que je veux dire
c'est que sa religion et sa foi on a le
droit de le critiquer au même titre que
manon religions et la laïcité ya passé
pas plus sacrées diam's que moi qui ne
suis pas religieuse déjà donc ça c'est
la première chose et ensuite tu disais
gilles qu' il n'y a pas de prosélytisme
il ya eu quand même dans dans son
discours quelque chose comme la musique
ses péchés elle a quand même une
pratique de l'islam qui moi à titre
personnel si tu veux moi malc est
absolument ce qu'elle veut de sa vie qui
moi me trouble et j'aimerais peut-être
pas que moi ma fille elles entendent par
exemple que la musique c'est péché ou
j'aimerais j'aimerais pas qu'on dise
aujourd'hui comme on le dit beaucoup
qu'elle est repenti et voilée comme si
finalement la musique c'était sale par
rapport à elle à sa pratique de la
religion voilà moi c'est vrai que j'ai
du mal avec ça mais de la même manière
que tu étais pas choqué par gueye qui ne
voulait pas mettre un un maillot contre
la lutte contre l'homophobie donc voilà
effectivement toi t'es pas choquée moi
ça me choque quand on dit par exemple
que la musique ses péchés à titre
personnel jim que tu répondras elle a
été sauvée par l'islam j'ai pas si vous
vous rendez compte dans ce qu'elle dit
l'islam la sauver l'état géraldine non
mais je la cite l'islam m'a sauvé atger
trouver la paix intérieure grâce à
l'islam ah ben c'est donc moi je trouve
ça beau l'âme venir dont elle parle de
religion et encore une fois je trouve
qu'il ya aucun prosélytisme quand elle
je crée musique ses péchés tu trouves ça
commente non mais elle dit
qu'aujourd'hui elle ne se reconnaît plus
dans ce monde rené lassus revenir c'est
un peu de temps voilà oui elle a quitté
ce monde pour autre chose aller dans une
pièce intérieure absolument mahmoud
abbas et donc on est d'accord mais donc
ceux qui traînent quelques critiques
choquant non maintenant parce qu'on a
droit de trouver que par exemple la
musique c'est pas pêcher on a droit de
combattre si elle a le droit de trouver
quel dans la musique elle s'est perdue
elle s'est perdue elle a failli en
mourir géraldine et les cela m'a sauvé
non mais ne pleure pas non plus ne m'en
fais pas trop ce que je veux dire c'est
que je
comprends très bien que la gloire n'est
absolument pas calmé les problèmes de
narcissisme et salenthal très bien et
justement je trouve que son son discours
effort est formidable mais malgré tout
je ne voudrais pas qu'on croie que
forcément dans la religion et toutes les
religions quelqu'elle soit on trouve un
apaisement et moi ça me gêne aujourd'hui
que quelqu'un d'autre si extraordinaire
qu'elle dise que la musique c'est péché
pardon ça me gêne à la 31ème sourates du
coran qui proscrit la musique voilà
c'est pour ça qu'elle a préféré arrêter
une fois qu'elle a été découverte voile
et à son insu et pour ça elle a pris la
décision d'adhérer jamais lavé de tous
moi je trouve qu'elle est moi je trouve
qu'elle est allée inattaquable dire oui
ce qu'est la wii elle a pris la décision
elle a été au bout de sa décision mais
moi je trouve ça très bien voilà après
et encore une fois je trouve qu'on parle
beaucoup trop de religion la religion
c'est intime c'est privé c'est pour elle
c'est pour moi
parce que là c'est une star a hérité
mois diom soit la vache est toujours été
fan d'elle de rêve c'est que je les
adore et que je les aime vraiment c'est
à lire elle est incroyable c'est une
femme incroyable au delà de l'artiste
vraiment et je trouve que c'est obliger
l obligé d'en parler puisque elle
explique pourquoi elle a arrêté au
salariat et elle participe aussi bien
voici une certaine manière ouais à laval
a été au bout de son truc ça fait des
années qu'elle a stationné à
cannes un documentaire
a dit quoi là son documentaire vaka la
france à messia la calade même pas
encore elle a bien elle est là elle l a
bien voulu qu'on fasse un documentaire
sur et le voilà prêt mais voilà elle a
préféré le faire à lui même avec ses
deux amies stars sont réalisatrice es
salaam ça veut dire paix et un pour ceux
qui le savent pas bon c'est important
moi j'ai regardé un peu de longs
extraits et c'est assez touchant parce
que raconte qu'à 15 ans elle avait déjà
fait une tentative de suicide qu'elle
était mal qu était bipolaire que et
c'est qu'elle a connu beaucoup de
problèmes et maintenant c'est la trouver
cette sérénité et cette paix intérieure
comme elle le dit dans le coran pourquoi
pas polaris pl via dubaï alors non c'est
faux alors c'est marrant ils disaient
ouais j'suis désolé mais elle a une
maison pas très loin de là où j'étais à
marrakech et d'ailleurs ça voisins de
ces vita et l'autre voisin c'est slim
and away ils chantent
parce que quand toyota
c'est sa meilleure amie mais ils
habitent dans le même truc a tantôt
vital si man ray parce que je sors
[Applaudissements]
de l'intérieur machinerie d'amour et
shimano et qui c'est qui veut ça c'est
de la folie
moi c'est ma génération donc ça me
touche pour moi diam's à
ckoi aussi c'est charles aznavour
alors oui donc moi ça me touche vraiment
pour moi diam's à les intouchables
pour revenir à ce que dit gg c'est pas
parce que on est connu on tire on dit
qu'un truc public que ça va spécialement
toucher nos enfants les enfants ils ont
eu des parents pour l'éducation
s'il veut les éduquer d'une certaine
manière bas c'est leur problème si
diam's l envie de dire que la musique
c'est interdit moi ça me dérange pas
qu'elle le dise si elle le pense
profondément chacun a le droit de penser
ce qu'il veut il colle un modèle pour
les jeunes c'est un modèle mais les
jeunes sont pas de baies et au caire ils
ont des parents si ça dérange les
parents la musique est proscrit bah
pourquoi pas après moi ce que j'aurais
aimé c'est qu'elle le dise plus tôt
voilà on nous on aurait aimé plus
d'explications plus tôt alors on est
hyper content qu'elle le fasse si
tardivement et c'est son choix mais moi
j'aurais même aimé aimer quelqu'un en
parle plutôt ma place à quelqu'un qui
n'est pas de
l'avis vraiment de se retirer mais vous
parle en tant que fan bien sûr ce qui a
surpris sa radicalité d'un coup comme ça
a l'air sûr que nous on l'a connu au
mois j'ai reçu 50 fois une fille
formidable sympathie joyeuse même en
avait toujours joyeuse elle était même
en boîte à cannes et tout ça de ma vie
extrêmement sympathique et des locaux le
truc plus étonnant c'est que vous soyez
en bois
soyez rentrée turbine et sert en retrait
ouais voilà c'est sa radicalité qui a
été
la convention et les
spiritualités voilà c'est une
spiritualité venir ça a été la soudaine
prise elle habitait
dans la soupe dans le giron des rémois
justement dans la soudaineté je suis pas
sûr que c'est ce que j'adorais moi j'ai
adoré ses hameaux cnt c'est très lourd
et sam aussi cette cohérence doit sans
lendemain de dire ça y est c'est bon
laissez moi tranquille moi je pars et on
est tous les gens qui critiquent
justement elle est partie même dans un
pays musulman à l'inversé au maroc donc
c'est tout et tout est cohérent tout est
cohérent après je peux comprendre que
les gens critiquent parce qu'ils pensent
qu'à là qu'elle fait la promotion de si
ça va mal dans votre vie tournez vous
vers la religion mais tu peux tourner
aussi vers l'église tu peux tourner dans
un appel aux religions en a différé dis
pas qu'il faut aller que dans l aide a
dit que c'est la religion musulmane qui
l'a sauvé et c'est vrai quand elle parle
moi je moi j'ai bien aimé quand elle dit
je savais pas où j'allais je me trompais
je faisais semblant de rire mon argent
nous série tout le monde ici tous autour
de nous vous êtes dans le showbiz vous
connaissez des gens qui font semblant
ils y vont et rigolent ils font semblant
de pas de cours est à l'intérieur ils
sont malheureux ils sont pas visibles
prennent du pognon mais sont très mal je
ne sai on chez eux sont tous à l'essai
il mange tout seul a répondu seul ils
sont tous seuls dans leur version ils
nous font chier tout savoir
mais moi je trouve qu'elle est d'une
cohérence implacable et va l'attaquer
bas si tout le monde faisait comme elle
de faire la religion à moitié il
s'arrête à 22 heures de sa religion que
la musique c'est péché pour elle mais
c'est pour elle
c'est tout et c'est aussi cohérent
qu'elle moi ça va
elle n'a pas dit aux gens d'écouter pas
de vue sa
musique il ya marchés dits choqués par
les critiques contre elle non mais donc
en fait oui je demande qu'on critique
que sa maman ta manière de pratiquer
fait noir à 10 kg ce qui dérange pas ce
qu'on dit c'est qu'elle ait choisi de
tourner d'un bébé reste anne-marie
qu'ils avaient fait légaliser alors
effet l'église quand tu rentres couvent
que les biens curé turne nature exacte
en août une romance à l'argent tu
regardes marion moyens
l'écuyer c'est dans la religion si elle
a permis de vivre mieux m c'est ce que
jean dionis est mal de se retourner vers
les jeux même si elle avait tu sa mort
la religion juive si elle avait mis
aujourd'hui vont alors on en regarde
religion tu vas bien que la religion
mais oui mais ce
que tu donc ce que tu dit géraldine
c'est pas son témoignage à elle qui
visiblement extrêmement sincère ce qui
te gêne c'est la récupération vie dans
life est oui d'un côté par l'extrême
droite et de l'autre côté par l'islam a
récupéré son thé moyens dans le sac et
vous avez vu regardez elle est peu
malheureuse grâce à une pratique
rigoriste il ya vous serez devant leurs
yeux verts si un dernier mot non moi je
trouvais géraldine que je suis fait un
mauvais procès parce que cette heure on
voit bien sur les réseaux sociaux elle
est attendue tout le temps il prépare
bien sûr elle pourrait faire du
prosélytisme vraiment où la suivrai
comme un guide spirituel elle ne le fait
pas quand elle répond à des questions
c'est vraiment à dose homéopathique
elle a préféré faire ce documentaire
elle-même justement pour qu'on ne fausse
pas ses propos mais franchement on peut
pas dire qu'elle se montrer qu'elle fait
du prosélytisme c'est un faux procès
d'âge de tous merci à tous d'avoir
attiré sûr on va voir ce qu'on pense et
téléspectateurs supplémentaires oui à
41% non à 58 pour s'envoyer un passé
récent les gens là ne sont pas stockées
par voilà les critiques contre diam's
league